Now let's discuss some of the issues with
scalability of the synchronization primitives in a shared
memory multiprocessor. Now we already saw that locks,
both mutual exclusion as well as shared lock is
one type of a synchronization operation. And we
also saw that barrier algorithms is another type of
synchronization operations. And when you look at both
of these guys Both of these types of synchronization
perimeters that a parallel operating system is going to
provide for application programmer
developing multi-threaded applications. The sources
of inefficiencies that come aboard is first of all
latency. What do we mean by that? Well, If
the thread wants to acquire this lock, it has
to do some operation. Has to go to memory,
get this lock, and make sure that nobody else
is competing with it. And, so that's the the
latency that is inherently what is the time that
is spent by a thread in acquiring the lock.
That's what we mean by latency. Well to be
more precise what we mean is that latency is
saying, lock is currently not being used. How long
does it take for me to go and get
it? That's really the key question that latency is,
is trying to, look at. The second source of scalabilty
with synchronization, is the waiting time, and that is if
I want to go and get the lock, how long do
I wait in order to get that lock? Well clearly
this is not something, that you and I as the
oldest designer has complete control over, because it really depends
on what these threads are doing with this lock. So
for instance, if this thread acquires this lock and, and
then it is modifying the data for a long time before
releasing it, and if another thread comes along
and wants the team lock, it's going to wait for
a long time. So the waiting time is really
in the purview of the application. And there's not
much you can do, as an OS designer, in
reducing the waiting time. The third source of unscalability
of locks is contention. What we mean by that
is. If currently some guy is using the lock,
and he releases it, when the lock is released, it's
now up for grabs. Maybe there's no, I've shown you only
one thread here, but maybe there's a bunch of threads
waiting here to access this particular lock. If they're all waiting
to access this lock, they're all contending for this lock.
And how long does it take in the presence of contention
for one of them to become the winner of the
Lock and the others to go away? So that's the contention
part of im, implementing a synchronization primitive.
And all of these things, latency, waiting time
and contention even though I mentioned it
in the context of a mutual exclusion lock
appears when you're talking about barrier synchronization,
algorithms, or shared locks. So latency and contention
are two things as all designers, we have
to be always worried about, and implementing scalelable
versions of synchronization primitives.